foreign
we have Bill calling from Midland
Michigan hey Bill welcome to the show
hey how's it going
hey great how can we help
um so thanks for everything you guys do
I've got a question my wife and I are
debt free aside from the house
and we're on four five and six right now
we both own our own businesses and
um so we sold our previous house last
year and we were able to put everything
we made on that one onto our current one
and only had to take out a loan for
about sixty thousand dollars awesome and
um finally bought a 210 000 purchase
which was awesome and a huge blessing
but so
I feel like and I think that we can pay
off said house by December of this year
if we keep saving what we're saving
currently and
um talk to my wife about it we only got
a little balance right now about
just over forty nine thousand on it
because we've been putting extra on it
too and
um had a conversation with her the other
day laid it all out and showed her and
she was on board with it and she was
just like
she said I'm I understand where you're
coming from and it's cool and I'm on
board with it but I'd like to talk to my
dad first together just to make sure
it's a wise idea because her dad's a CPA
and I'd say all this prefacing the fact
that I respect my father-in-law a lot we
have a great relationship I respect his
opinion but he's also not necessarily
like
you know that's uh that care kind of guy
you know like he buys he kind of like
he's bought like a car on loans every
couple years carries credit cards which
two is their own like whatever but we're
on I feel like we're on different levels
of that idea and so I was like well I'll
talk to him but I probably already know
what he's gonna say
and so we had the conversation and he
was like well I don't see the point of
paying off such a small loan with such a
small interest rate
and you could just save up cash I was
like well I feel like we could pause our
investing for a couple months in order
to do this
and then restart the process of that
he's like well I wouldn't invest right
now either because the Market's crap and
I was like well what would you do oh
goodness gracious you would you want to
pay off the house and you wouldn't
invest and he's like I just pile up cash
I was like but we we've done that and so
my question is what should we do the
conversation to football and politics
and you do you when it comes to money
now does your father-in-law pay your
bills does he pay your mortgage no okay
just wanted to make sure and I'm right
there with you like I he has an opinion
but his opinion is not the final vote
yeah I can have deep respect for the man
I can love him same thing with my dad
you know we talk money and I get
frustrated and we change the subject
because we are not going to agree and I
say thank you for your opinion we are
not taking a poll at this time uh what's
for dinner you know and so I think
that's and that's the relationship
well my whole thing with it too is like
so there's a kind of a two-parter is
like yes it'll take out a lot of our
savings but we'll still have an
emergency fund left over if we wait till
December to do this because we'll have
at least five months of saving saved up
and then we'll be able to save that
money right back up plus then you know
the house payment every single month
yeah and we both own our own businesses
I'm my wife owns a CrossFit gym and I'm
a massage therapist so aside from
pandemics and what not ever happening
again like physically I don't know when
my last day of work's ever going to be
yeah you know and I make good money
right now so I'd rather get everything
paid off now while I make good money so
that later I don't want to worry about
that when I need to take a different job
that's a great mentality on top of that
bill I would not pause investing so if
you're doing four five and six you're
investing 15 if you've got kids you're
putting some away for college and then
anything left over we're throwing at the
house so I do agree if you want to go
down to you know four month emergency
fund and put the rest on the house and
get this thing paid off man you're gonna
sleep better and your father-in-law
while probably a lovely person doesn't
get a vote when it comes to what you do
with your money so when you guys are so
close to the Finish Line like a December
payoff that is going to be a debt-free
house that you're going to keep for
years moving forward so that's just
going to let you walk on that freedom
and I think you're right as a business
owner that security that comes from
having no mortgage no payments in the
world it's just it's going to change the
way you approach business it's going to
help you feel so much more free so yeah
I agree football maybe politics I
personally wouldn't I stay away from all
of that I stay away from both honestly
Sports politics I know very little about
either I'll stick to money money but